[Music]
reversing president trump's america
first agenda will be priority number one
for the biden presidency
the president-elect is planning
immediate executive actions
they reportedly include rejoining the
paris climate deal
reversing the travel ban and cancelling
the keystone
xl pipeline and check out this headline
from the la times
make america california again that's
biden's plan
the paper explains how the golden state
is emerging as a quote de facto policy
think tank
for the biden team jesse i i i wanted to
start with you and just say
it seems to me a new president
implementing
new plans uh what's the surprise there i
mean
isn't that to be expected that elections
have consequences and a new guy is going
to have a new agenda
if biden had run on emulating california
he would have lost
why would you emulate california
everyone's leaving california won
it's like record energy prices record
homelessness record covid
record bankruptcies i mean why don't you
emulate texas
and then also what about the keystone
pipeline you're getting energy
from our ally sent down to us to be
refined here
made in america a pipeline built through
union labor
that tells opec to take a hike and keeps
energy prices low at the pump
it's good for national security and jobs
why would you get rid of that
oh just to pay off your green donors is
that how this is going to be
and then all of a sudden you go to the
mideast instead of consolidating those
gains there you have four sunni arab
states
now aligned with israel against the
iranians
they're more isolated and broke than
ever before and you're just going to
walk
and just to burnish john kerry's legacy
it's asinine
i don't know what the guy's thinking i
said i'd be fair so i'm going to wait
until he does it
but it's not looking good
all right so dana joe biden when he was
running for president promised to spend
money to help people
get the covet vaccine to help people who
have been
hard hit by the covet economy shouldn't
he keep those promises
well i think that americans actually
separate out the relief from
the need for coveted monies which we all
need and we all are going to
agree on that but some of these other
things are pretty incredible a friend of
mine said it's like the biden
administration
looked through the twitter feed of the
far left and just picked out a whole
bunch of random things and put them
together
um two things on the pipeline um jesse
did you know that even the canadians
say that it will meet their it will
allow them to meet
their uh greenhouse gas emissions
reductions so if the canadians
are okay with it surely americans should
be able to be okay with it
the other thing is the idea of doing the
15 an hour minimum wage
okay if you want to do that fine but
that would mean ignoring the
congressional budget office that says
that um 3.7 million jobs could be lost
because of that
there are um yes elections have
consequences but so do some of these
policies
so greg part of this is the use of
executive
orders uh biden says he's going to use
executive orders to do
things and you know rejoin the climate
deal and the like
but isn't that a response to the fact
that president trump
used executive orders to undo a lot of
what obama had done
that's you're absolutely right that's
the problem with executive orders
is that they can be done and then they
could be undone it's the post-election
ritual right
but in this case it's something else
it's a retribution strategy
i'm gonna coin a phrase they're throwing
the baby out
with the bath water because they hate
trump so much
they are willing to undo all of the
positive things that even they secretly
admit
were positive building a strong economy
the increased wages the trade
transparency
the relationship with north korea the
peace agreements in the middle east
the cheap energy they are so vindictive
and not just about trump but about trump
supporters trump voters that they're
willing
to punish people for this in in a
completely broad manner so what does it
say that to hurt trump means that you
hurt americans
it means and i know you're going to hate
this it means that his goals
and intentions exactly aligned with the
american interests
i had a cab driver in kiev who was
driving me he was very nervous he says
do you mind if i ask you about
the election i said sure go ahead he
goes i don't like what mr trump did to
our country but i would love to have him
as my president and the reason why he
said that
i interpret it is that trump was our
agent
he was our lawyer you don't want an
agent or a lawyer
that other people like you want an agent
or a lawyer that nobody wants to deal
with
and that's what trump was trump was our
a-hole lawyer
and now we've got our benign bureaucrat
who will basically
roll over for anybody and that is joe
biden
emily uh you know when you think about
reversing the travel ban rejoining the
climate accords
according to the polls most americans
think yeah go ahead and do it
well that's why i think the
responsibility would be on the
republican party to
explain to the american people why
disengaging or rejoining
those policies or those plans etc are in
their best interest and they need to be
clear and they need to perpetuate that
rather than
for this example attacking the democrats
and just a quick point about
biden it's in his best interest to play
in the center
and to do moderate things because if he
embarks on this far
left path and takes america down this
totally liberal path right away
then come 2022 there will be a red tidal
wave and then the rest of his presidency
is basically over